if you want to hear about how every
story from the original trilogy of scary
stories books was used in the movie then
stick around to the end of this video it
is the fall of 1968 in a small town
called Mill Valley Pennsylvania and
Halloween is being celebrated in full
force one thing I noticed was a poster
for the Halloween or double bell which
presumably was a reference to the double
feature taking place at the drive-in
where we would later see the characters
watch Night of the Living Dead but the
double bill might also be self
referential because at the end of the
movie we learned that the ending is left
open for a possible sequel that's not
the only bit of foreshadowing early on
one of the main characters chuck wants
to be spider-man for Halloween but his
mom ends up making him a literal spider
costume his sister Ruth Baker's with him
because she sees him as a pest pun
intended the first example of her
distaste for arachnids
shortly after when they go to check out
the haunted house we see that the place
is crawling with spiders and at the end
of that sequence
Tommy pushes Ruth into the locked room
where she gets spider webs caught in her
hair which is likely where she first
receives the bite that becomes infected
with spider eggs known as the red spots
but I'll discuss that further when we
get to it first let's talk about the
first supernatural site the old lady
with the black Doberman seen by Chuck in
the haunted house this is likely part of
the corrupt Bella's family that we
learned more about throughout the movie
but the imagery of a black dog is one
that comes up a couple times in alvin
Schwartz's trilogy of books most notably
the appropriately titled story the black
dog from the third book in that story a
man named Peter Rothberg lives alone in
an old house every night at 11 p.m.
honestly surprised it's not 3 a.m. for
once a mysterious black dog appears and
runs down the stairs
he tries night after night to catch it
but it's unsuccessful until one day his
neighbor sets up downstairs with a
pistol the dog disappears never to be
seen again
but he can still hear the dog running on
most nights like the dog in the story
this is the only time that Chuck gets a
good look at the dog and naturally his
friends don't believe him at first
Stella and Ramone happen across the room
that Sarah bellows was locked away in
and it's there that they discovered two
items the music box
and Sarah's book of scary stories when
they find the book there are a number of
stories already written inside and they
correspond to actual stories in the
that the movie is sourced from the ones
that I noticed included may I carry your
basket a story about a man who offers
help to an old woman out in the cold one
night with her basket only to discover
that the basket contains her head which
attacks him somebody fell from aloft the
story of a mysterious corpse that falls
into a ship at sea the ghost with the
bloody fingers the story of a bloody
hand that haunts hotel guests Hook the
story of an escaped convict with a hook
for a hand strangers a story about a man
who meets a woman reading ghost stories
on the train who proclaims that he
doesn't believe in ghosts only to see
the woman vanish before him the attic
about a guy who steps on a nail in the
attic cat's paw about a man who shoots
the cat who's continually stealing meat
from his smokehouse only to discover
that it was actually a shape-shifting
witch who was also plot twist his
neighbor's wife and Wendigo the story of
a hunter who goes out on a trip with a
Native American guide named
Defago a name I'm sure he never got made
fun of at all during middle school for
who essentially gets dragged away by
this Algonquian mythological creature
known as the one that yeah then there's
a blank page and on the page after that
Stella sees the beginnings of another
story Harold she smears the red ink with
her finger as if to suggest that the
words had just been written and the ink
or as we later find a blood was fresh in
the movie the JA character Tommy lives
on a farm with his mother and he and his
friends continually abused the Scarecrow
Harold by throwing bottles and hitting
it with the bat until one night Harold
comes to life and stabs Tommy with a
pitchfork causing him to turn into an
ugly scarecrow the involvement of the
character Tommy is kind of hidden in
plain sight in the movie because the
story in the book centers around two
farmers one of which is named Thomas in
the book they create Harold to resemble
a farmer that they don't like and
similarly abuse the Scarecrow but
instead of turning Thomas into a
scarecrow
Harold skins him and sets his skin out
to dry in the Sun the next story to play
out in the movie is the big toe
unlike Harold's the name of the
character and the big toe is never
stated but in the movie the named August
4 responds with one of Stella's two best
friends Auggie in the book the boy finds
the toe out in the garden so his mom
puts it into her soup which is
ridiculous so in the movie he just finds
it a stew which appears in the fridge
and it contains the toe and other
various body parts the next story is the
Red Spot which is another one where the
name of the character Ruth nicely
corresponds with the name of the
character from the original story in
Routh's Boyle bursts to release the
spiders who had nested in her face while
she's in the bath but in the movie she
rushes to the school bathroom before her
production of Bye Bye Birdie which was
likely chosen because it's about a rock
star named Conrad birdie who is to
perform one last hit before being
drafted into the army much like how the
character Ramones final act is helping
rescue Stella before he's taken overseas
by the draft the kids try to rush to
save Ruth from popping open the red spot
but accidentally run into the wrong
bathroom where there were these four
girls just standing there in the dark
wait what was going on in that for his
bathroom put anyway after that they go
to visit Lulu Baptiste who was a
matching music box to the one we
previously saw in sera bellows his room
but this time we get to hear it play and
the tune is a song known as the Hurst
song you see the scary stories books are
not only filled with scary stories but
also game slash pranks to play at
Halloween parties or songs complete with
lyrics and sheet music I'm not a
musician but I was able to recognize the
melody from the only lyrics that Lulu
mentions about the worms crawling and
the fact that there's an audiobook
version where some old guy sings the
song roll it goes by four you may be the
next to die they wrap you up in a big
white sheet from your head oh no this
song is so scary but it's around this
time that Chuck starts to mention that
he's been having this recurring dream
which eventually leads to his own scary
encounter where this creature known as
the pale lady corners him from every
direction and eventually catches him and
absorbs him the book version is similar
but with different circumstances an
artist named Lucy Morgan decides to go
out of town to do some painting but her
destination changes after a pale lady in
a dream tells her that this is an evil
place she ends up going to a town called
Dorset and when she goes to look at her
room it's the same one as the location
from her dream just like how Chuck's
dream had described the red room which
is a room in the hospital that the kids
are looking for Lucy ends up fleeing the
town after seeing the pale lady from her
dream but Chuck isn't so lucky the next
one is one that I really did not expect
to see in the movie adaptation meet
Dody waka a story from the original
scary stories to tell in the dark book
the film version has our characters
locked in a jail cell where this
character called the gangly man
assembles itself after the dog at the
police station watches its body parts
fall down the chimney and it goes after
Ramon the book kind of establishes the
legend that Ramon and Stella encounter
it tells of a man who offers $200 to
anyone who stays in this haunted house
overnight a boy decides to try it and
goes there with his dog he goes there
and hears someone in the distance
singing the lyrics me tied o T Walker
and then his dog responds by singing
Lynn cheek in cheek alley Mali dingo
dingo if you listen to the dogs grunting
in the film it actually sounds like he's
grunting these lyrics the singing gets
closer and closer until the head falls
down the chimney and in the book that's
where it ends but the movie really takes
it a step further by having it be the
head of a creature that continues to
come after Ramon that would seemingly be
the last one but we eventually come to
find that this entire thing was part of
one big scary story and that is the
haunted house here's the lowdown in the
haunted house it's the tenth story in
book number one and it follows a
preacher who goes to investigate a house
I do have been haunted for the last 10
years the ghost of a woman appears and
tells the preacher the story of how her
husband killed her for her money
and buried her in the cellar she
instructs the man to give her a proper
burial and put her finger in the
collection plate at church where we'll
stick to the man who was guilty after
he's done this she'll tell him where the
money is hidden and it is the key this
may not sound like anything from the
movie until you consider the fact that
this is essentially the whole movie
these kids wander into a haunted house
and come across the book from Sara
bellows little by little they learn more
and more about how her family abused her
and killed her for trying to expose the
truth about how her family's papermill
poisoned the water supply and got some
kids killed she's bringing her killers
to justice just as the woman's ghost in
the haunted house story did and instead
of publicly exposing the killer as seen
in the book she gets Stella the girl who
a few short days ago was too afraid to
write for her school newspaper to write
in the book and bring out the truth
about Sara's death even though I'm
pretty sure it's been 70 years and
nobody cares anymore
but still if it's one small action
somehow fixes everything it's just like
it was told in the beginning of the
movie stories hurt and stories heal and
we roll the credits which are played
over the graphics done in the same style
as the original artwork from the book
trilogy so that's it scary stories to
tell in the dark and number one I also
recently did a video on the top
five things you missed from it's number
one so click that video on the left if
you want to see that and if you like
horror you're definitely gonna want to
subscribe to seize these world because I
upload new Horrors every week bring that
death battle for notifications and I'll
see you in the next video
assuming we both survive